- [Voiceover] Is this what Bitcoin is?
- [Voiceover] I'm glad Men's Wearhouse
sponsored me in the Hunger Games.
- [Voiceover] Adopting as a single man
in his 30s was challenging, but worth it.
- [Voiceover] I can't
believe I have to work
on that project with Honeybee.
I fucking hate that dude.
- [Voiceover] I heard
you were talking shit.
- [Voiceover] Bitch, no,
you talk to Panda Bear
about that shit.
- [Voiceover] Ho, don't do it.
- [Voiceover] I don't know
if I was rushing or dragging.
- [Voiceover] I know our
quarterly earnings are down
40 percent, but I'm
gonna dance by this lake.
- [Voiceover] I'm sure
Lorraine is hard at work
on those reports.
- [Voiceover] Nothing
like hot tea on the beach.
- [Voiceover] Oh my god, our
shadows are making out again.
- [Voiceover] Ugh, get
a room, our shadows.
- [Voiceover] Simmons, you land this
switch front side bigger spin
and the promotion is yours.
- [Voiceover] Why does Madison always
get to be out of focus?
- [Voiceover] Is this what Cross Fit is?
- [Voiceover] I can't believe
the Ark of the Covenant
qualified for prime.